you have seen him in Lost in oz in Zero
Dark Thirty Sons of Anarchy and so much
more he's currently in the second season
of his show from and Harold parano is
here now Harold good to see you good to
see you too John good to talk to you
yeah there's a burning question that I
think a lot of people want to know the
answer to Harold and that is when your
agent comes to you with scripts do you
automatically say no if the title has
more than one word because hurting Oz
and lost and Claws and from so if
there's more than one word is that a
hard no for you yeah Zero Dark Thirty it
took a lot of convincing you for me to
go and work with Catherine Bigelow too
many words
you wanted it to just be zero and zero
no man I just happen to be lucky to find
myself in these uh positions to work
with those great people so I got lucky I
can imagine people still come up to you
all the time and want to talk about lost
is that true all the time and especially
not because of from you know we're
working with Jack bender and Jeff pink
now Jack Bender was our executive
director on law Chef people came worked
a couple of Seasons so those guys know
how to tell those kind of stories and so
there's a lots of comparisons that were
our own separate thing in lost you got
to play the good guy and the bad guy you
did both you know quite well do you
enjoy you know sort of playing one more
than the other and are people still
asking you what happened to Walt all the
time that's the answer said where's Walt
yo bro I thought that'd be funny it's
like yeah 20 70 times ago when I dude
over there did it wouldn't stop
um so so uh you know I like playing
characters that have to make choices and
then you decide whether he's good or bad
like for me Michael was always a good
guy on lost and but there are people
that just hated that dude so like I like
playing characters that give you the
opportunity to have uh your opinion
about them and I just go and I play them
I feel that about Boyd and from I felt
that about Michael I thought that about
Augustus Hill in uh in in Oz I I I like
those you know questionable Humanity
characters I think it makes us
you know not see everybody as such
villains we go like oh I bet you there's
a reason for that or maybe there wasn't
I still don't like you but I get it you
know
you know I think that's a cool thing
uh okay I won't ask you about Walt
anymore
um
it was it was me it was me